[Musique]
je ne contrôle plus il arrive malheur
mais ça fait du bien mesdames et
messieurs de la nasa ici charles xavier
les secours arrivent une mission
spatiale comme on va chercher les
astronautes on les ramène go la
température augmente très vite il faut
dégager d'ici oui jean où elle est
tu
elle devrait être morte tu sais comment
ils t'appellent les jeunes ici phoenix
bonjour aux jeans
qui es tu la vraie question est toi qui
es tu
je vous êtes en train de m'arriver quand
je ne me contrôle plus il arrive malheur
mais ça fait du bien
cette force a détruit tout ce qui est
jamais croisé sa route
jusqu'à toi les x-men que craignent
ce qu'ils craignent ils cherchent à le
détruire
elle va tous nous tuer
il faut la détruire
c'est toujours notre ami ce n'est plus
jean
massé
en effet très mauvaise idée
g
[Musique]